feeling right now he's leaning back and  body language in chess we've talked  about it a bit but if a player leans  back either they're very confident or  they know their position is hopeless  yeah well this will certainly make some  of our twitter audience very happy  because magnus of course has a lot of  support and carly roche  says uh just champs  chess let's go magnus in her selfie  there she is supporting magnus and  lavinia bratis says  chess all the way and this time she has  a chest maestro biscuit  oh very very tasty we're jealous i never  oh never heard of it  but they sell them here in norway really  yeah oh we have a result  yep young christophe duda has resigned  magnus carlsen is actually shaking his  head but  it is a win for the world champion an  important win for him actually and uh  are you surprised due to the  this early david yes